[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts if you want to come to Austin
Texas
to play one-on-one not again I will
donate fifty thousand dollars to the
charity of your choice if you win but if
I win you have to make your Instagram
public for a year
and
you have to post an apology video that I
approve of
so the choice is yours do you want to
give them fifty thousand dollars
whatever weather charity
do you want to play ball come on down
man One on One Two Eleven by ones old
school and uh you know it'll be recorded
it'll be shot but you'll have your shot
you can be real funny during it and uh
total Destruction by you so let's see
what you got I think you're too much of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you won't do it but
choice is yours two weeks ago we posted
a video summarizing the ongoing Tom
Segura vs Erie Pennsylvania beef that
has taken the podcast World by storm
since then a lot more has transpired
between Tom and the local Erie
weatherman so in today's video we're
diving back into sagora versus Erie but
this time with some all new information
real quick before we get started on that
happy New Year and welcome back to the
joke World comedy update every single
Monday bringing you all the comedy news
that you need to know from your favorite
comedians and your favorite podcast it's
a sports center for comedy so if you
want to stay in the comedy Loop be sure
to subscribe to joke world right now go
follow us on Instagram for some even
more comedy content in your life and
download this episode on Spotify or
apple wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show it's so fun to [ __ ] on
a plate I mean like I hate Erie
Pennsylvania so much the Erie
Pennsylvania such a [ __ ] dump a bunch
of losers it's a depressed town with a
depressed economy and if you live there
you know you're a [ __ ] zero if you
still haven't watched our original video
summing up the Saga between Tom segor
and Erie Pennsylvania I don't know what
you're doing we're going to link it up
right here so you can watch it real
quick then come back to this video but
but long story short he made some jokes
on two bears one cave at erie's expense
and the town took it very hard they went
crazy they were playing it on the news
they interviewed their local mayor about
it I guess he's not a local mayor it's
just their mayor they interviewed their
mayor about it but no one took it harder
than their local weatherman David
Walters the weatherman like gets in his
little equip which is like it's a it's
kind of a you know a staple of local
broadcasts right where they kind of go
between the anchor and the news guy
hired for Tom the reason he's so mad is
because he wasn't voted in the top 10 of
the sexiest bald men alive that's what
I'm here okay so he burned me hard on
that one and then I got notified that he
you know first thing he did was he
posted about this right and he tells
everybody to those who follow me because
of the weather
you might be noticing a lot of weird
comments it's apparently the result of
Tom Segura hates Erie that was about a
month back I made a funny comment about
Tom word got out to his fan base so they
are swarming my social media accounts
with a bunch of his sayings
uh the posts were comical for 24 hours
but that's about it if you have a legit
weather question just DM me and I will
answer it please don't post in the
comment section all right well that's
gonna change
[Laughter]
for sure
um today is one of the biggest travel
days of the year but for the Tom Segura
and then he put in caps basement Club so
now he thinks he's like really jabbing
them you know
uh the walk up the stairs to your
parents rent-free kitchen should be easy
enough if you need some work I hear the
Falcon so it was awesome not Tom so now
he's like just trying to you know insult
all like lump them in as all basement
here's the thing most of them didn't
know about this but now they all will
so and here's the thing about them it
doesn't matter where you go
you can start new social media wherever
it is whatever you want to call yourself
you got a whole new group of people
following you good luck and leaving you
comments for the rest of your [ __ ]
career since all this is aired David
actually made his Instagram public again
and his comment section is an absolute
bloodbath if you have a legit weather
question I definitely go recommend
checking out David Walters comment
section at one point he was begging to
come on your mom's house playtime
one-on-one in basketball to which now
Tom has actually agreed accepted to play
him one-on-one but with some additional
stakes in terms of his own he puts the
the gift of me you know breaking my [ __ ]
he goes I've decided instead of being on
yma Studios I want to play Tom Segura in
a game of Hoops I'll wear jeans too high
and tight and then he run and then
underneath it he puts it will be total
Destruction by me I'll take you up on
that and here's what I'll do if you want
to come to Austin Texas oh no to play
one-on-one not again I will donate fifty
thousand dollars to the charity of your
choice if you win
you can name any charity and I'll give
them 50 Grand
but if I win you have to make your
Instagram public for a year
and
you have to post an apology video that I
approve of
since Tom issued this challenge there's
yet to be an official response from the
weatherman but with all this going on
Tom vs Erie the comedy World altogether
I thought it would make sense to talk to
someone with boots on the ground in Erie
Pennsylvania who also has ties to the
comedy world so we were able to reach
out to a local Erie comedian Jerry
Nielsen to shed some light on this
ongoing drama I gotta start off just by
asking you what the general Vibe has
been like in Erie since all this started
happening are people pissed do they
think it's cool that a famous comedian
is talking about your city how are
people been responding to this whole
thing since it started all the old
people who would like Erie really don't
like Tom Segura right now all the really
relevant people like who's gonna get out
of Erie it totally agrees with cigarette
I mean either he just kind of sucks as a
whole my grandma watches the local news
and she told me that uh he's very mad at
Sugar
yeah he takes a lot of pride in this
city
um I think it's really all he has is
yeah reporting weather in here you know
it's
to give him I mean you got to give it up
it's a good time to report weather and
you know there's a lot of weird stuff
happening here but yeah I think he's
actually like kind of mad yeah it seems
that way and I'm from I'm from Northeast
Ohio which is basically it's very close
to Erie so I know you know I I feel like
I know exactly what it's like there and
I get both stances like a a reasonable
person will be like yeah I'm like where
I'm from I have some sort of pride in it
but there's way better places out there
and it's and what Tom was saying is
funny so if it's funny you know which
leads me into my next question as a
comedian and an eerie resident you're
kind of in the middle of this whole
thing seems like you have more of a
nuanced stance on it but what have you
had any thoughts of like I want to side
with my town or I want to side with the
comedian here
um
we were you know we were thinking about
doing a clap back video at Tom and then
you know
it's just it's I think what really made
this a big deal was Joe Rogan being
there as well you know did you hear
about that challenge and do you think
that your weatherman should accept that
can he hoop do you know do what do you
think you should do there it'd be good
for his name to accept the challenge if
he wanted to get out of here you know I
think you would accept the challenge but
I think ultimately he's not gonna accept
that you know it'd be cool if Tom came
here and did that you know helped out I
was saying like you could help out the
local comedy scene here you know but you
know we can only be hopeful this can be
a strange time of year for most
professions in between Christmas and New
Year's where there's really not a lot
going on and that also applies to Comedy
usually we have a lot more to cover on
the joke World comedy update but many of
our favorite comedians and podcasts
decide to take a well-deserved holiday
break this year and instead of posting
their regular scheduled programs
uploaded a bus of 2022 highlight reel
it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds Walden was one of the
big time Joe you gotta cover your mouth
I mean in normal life but in these times
you're just blowing it out into
everybody sorry I went over that way I
got nervous that I was gonna
no there was something
there was a lot going on I got it right
to the end no I just I did
I just there was no snot expel
I got a little nervous I got nervous
that I would take us through it what
happened when did you get nervous at
what point I just panicked that I was
going to sneeze your way so then I
turned and then I was going to cover my
and then I was like What if I get
something on my hand and I touched on my
and I was like but if you don't get
something on your hand that means
nobody's over there that's a clear but
but you didn't know if you want to get
something on your hands so rather you
get it on the carpet I I knew I wasn't
going to get anything onto the car I
don't know I just panicked leave me
alone now I know everyone subscribing to
this channel is a big fan of
compilations obviously so I have the
full list for you here every podcast
that's posted a best of 2022 episode on
YouTube starting off with flagrant are
you garbage Chrissy chaos patreon hey
babe the Honeydew and Bert cast guest
spots from last week your mom's house
had on Josh Wolf two bears one cave was
Burton Tom and Bert whiskey Ginger had
on Rachel Feinstein kill Tony had on Ron
White flagrant upload their best of 2022
moments and bad friends uploaded an
episode from The Vault today is a
special day as you guys know we took a
little bit of a break
but I have rescue From the Vault an
episode that was discarded early this
year uh I had to do a little surgery on
it but uh you guys will let me know if
they if if you find it funny uh Andrew
and Bobby don't know that this is gonna
be out so hopefully we don't lose our
jobs after this yeah this was one that I
think was said not to be released
exactly but we needed an episode and we
didn't want to have to record one real
fast with the guy so get mad that we
messed up so right we're just gonna put
this one out for y'all this past weekend
in theovan was a solo episode The Joe
Rogan Experience had on Brian redband
which is always a classic we might be
drunk talk with Sebastian the Honeydew
had on Josh Wolf and tigerbelly had on
Rudy jewels from Bad friends as far as
new stand-up specials go heading into
2023 Andrew Santino cheeseburger comes
out in eight days that'll be on Netflix
January 10th very excited for Andrew
Santino's new special we'll definitely
do a video recapping fans reactions to
that one so keep an eye out for that
orney Adams has the new hour out on you
YouTube right now called takes the third
and Netflix put out a best stand-up
moments from 2020 Montage on their
platform but if you're interested in the
top five specials from 2022 the top five
comedy stem specials from 2022 go check
out our latest video on joke world
that's the real list that does it for
this episode of the joke World comedy
update the first episode of 2023 thank
you so much for the support last year
Keeping Up With The Comedy news it's
been really fun reporting on all this
comedy news so thank you to everyone who
subscribed and liked and commented
interacted with these videos so far make
sure to go follow us on Instagram and
fill up the form in the bio if you want
any of these free stickers if you've
dm'd us for stickers in the past and
have not received them it's because you
need to go fill out the form in the bio
now the the DMS are too full too full to
manage which is a [ __ ] awesome thing
thank you guys so much I love you for
the support and for I just love you for
everything I guess
I got very intimate at the end of this
one thank you so much I'll see you guys
next time with the news uh try not to
laugh Dan Soder coming out on Wednesday
turn your post notifications on it's
gonna be a good one by the way to the
fans please serious weather questions
[Music]